bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement et dont l'essentiel de l'info
politique et parlementaire avec michael
shannon jojo katia 45 minutes d'émission
et c'est parti en images avec le choc
air france les violences qui ont émaillé
le comité central d'entreprise du groupe
des dirigeants molesté malmené en
haillons les images ont fait le tour du
monde une réaction politique presque
unanimes pour condamner les faits la loi
santé en débat les sénateurs ont rejeté
la généralisation du tiers payant décrié
par les médecins la ministre marisol
touraine promet le retour de la mesure à
l'assemblée nationale et puis cet
événement historique au parlement
européen françois hollande et en gala
merkel se sont montrés côte à côte dans
l'hémicycle de strasbourg cela ne
s'était pas produit depuis la
réunification allemande le chef de
l'état s'est fait interpeller par marine
le pen en séance plénière notre invité
cette semaine pour commenter toute cette
actualité beaux jours bruno le roux
l'argent c'est le patron des députés
socialistes à l'assemblée nationale vous
connaissez la musique de l'émission on
va regarder un petit portrait s'est
pressée par les parlementaires eux mêmes
puis vous réagissez juste après merci il
est capable d'avancer mais d'écouter de
prendre des décisions fermes quand il
faut et en même temps
toujours dans le dialogue écoute
j'ai rassemblement à fois autoritaire me
semble-t-il et en rondeur le porte
d'ailleurs un peu sur lui et
assez affable courtois et
c'est un petit clin vrai fédérateur et
sept armes président de groupe avec
lequel il est très facile de travailler
il a jamais réellement permis que des
débats contradictoires sérieux étayer
les lieux sur la politique que l'on
menait c'est vraiment quelqu'un de très
fidèle mais en même temps il faut pas
trop lui faire je pense qu'il ya une
chose qui ne supporte pas ces contrats
hills ou qu'on lui mente et dans les
deux cas de figure il vaut mieux avoir
une opinion différente allez le voir et
lui en parler plutôt que de le faire en
cachette alors là là il peut mordre très
très fort l'adaptation si je me trompe
ou pas que vous êtes devenu
irremplaçable à la tête du groupe parce
que vous avez interrogé ça m'aurait
manqué qui est pas beau mais là dedans
parce que quand même normal faut
toujours qu'ils aient quelque chose
qu'ils n'aillent pas avec lui mais en
même temps vous avez interrogé des
députés qui représentent je crois la
grande majorité mais qui sont ses vrais
parmi ceux qui me soutiennent mais
personne ne tirant pas irremplaçable
oui alors je ramène à ma femme je
regrette qu'il n'ait pas vu les efforts
que je fais pour faire du sport et pour
reperdre un peu de rondeur ces derniers
temps mais à l'elysée mais juste des
ponots est prête même à l'elysée on dit
on pourrait pas enlever bruno le roux de
la présidence du groupe en assembler si
c'est la marque d'une fidélité d'une
loyauté voire même d'une compétence dans
le travail qui est fait ici tant mieux
c'est comme ça que je veux que l'on voit
la responsabilité du président de groupe
6 e pour dire que personne ne pourrait
faire ce travail mais bien entendu
personne les ti remplaçable il y a
aujourd'hui au sein de mon groupe des
députés particulièrement des gens
expérimentés
spécialiste sur ce que sont les
problèmes parlementaire et donc personne
n'est irremplaçable alors on va dérouler
la semaine avec vous lundi la colère des
salariés d'air france qui ont pourchassé
leur patron dans la violence les images
ont fait le tour du monde un peu comme
le symbole de l'échec du dialogue social
à la française
le comité central d'entreprise du groupe
a dégénéré le drh a été contraint
d'escaladé un grillage pour échapper à
la colère de manifestants déchaînés ils
venaient d'annoncer la suppression de
2900 postes est là mon magasin
tout dirigeant d'air france chemise en
lambeaux force et d'escaladé un grillage
pour rejoindre les forces de l'ordre et
se mettre à l'abri d'un groupe de
manifestants survoltés
des images qui ont fait la une de la
presse nationale et internationale
et qui ont choqué les politiques de tous
bords le comité central d'entreprise
d'air france a tourné au pugilat la
direction venait d'annoncer un nouveau
plan de restructuration
2009 100 suppressions de postes avec
pour la première fois deux probable
licenciement c'est la manifestation qui
se tenait dehors a alors dégénéré
si l'ensemble de la classe politique a
condamné les violences les analyses ne
sont pas les mêmes à l'extrême gauche
par exemple on rappelle une autre
brutalité ces salariés qui sont menacés
aujourd'hui
ils sont un peu comme des condamnés en
puissance avec leur chemise pour monter
sur l'échafaud de la suppression
d'emplois l'opposition elle met en avant
la responsabilité de l'état où est
l'état actionnaire qui doit taper du
poing sur la table pour faire cesser
cette chienlit tu porte atteinte à la
des fleurons d'autres pays chiant lit un
mot utilisé par nicolas sarkozy lors de
la réunion du groupe des républicains
manuel valls agréé pic la chienlit le
mot que nous avons déjà entendu en fin
de matinée la remise en cause permanente
des corps intermédiaires des syndicats
de l'indépendance de la justice de ceux
qui font de même la démocratie ce mot
chienlit l'expression qui a été aussi la
vôtre comme celles de nicolas sarkozy
sont des mots dangereux si air france a
porté plainte la direction a par
ailleurs affirmé souhaiter reprendre les
négociations
bruno le roux l'échec d'air france est
l'échec de la france c'est l'échec de
l'état actionnaire c'est l'échec de tig
ou ce serait l'échec de la france en
tout cas un grave coup pour la france si
air france devait devenir ce que
j'appelle une compagnie de seconde zone
tu avais la question des avions avec le
pavillon français en l'air ils
existeront toujours question est de
savoir à quoi il nous rallierons quel
type de contrat sera celui de ceux qui
travailleront et surtout quel sera le
détenteur du capital il faut que l'état
s'engage plus
qu'est ce que vous dites deux rapports
j'ai rendu un rapport rendu un rapport
il ya un an maintenant où je disais la
difficulté du transport aérien français
pour autant quand je vois mes
interlocuteurs je leur dis quelquefois
je regrette quelquefois d'avoir formulé
ses propositions parce que il ne faut
pas les prendre comme exonérant les
compagnies d'un travail à faire sur leur
propre compétitivité et rien ne pourra
sauver air france l'état ne pourra pas
sauver air france demain si air france
ne se sauve pas d'abord elle même les
pilotes sont responsables aussi dans
cette situation il refuse de faire des
efforts mais au moment où nous parlons
des discussions sont en train d'y passer
et donc moi je souhaite que tout le
monde prenne sa part à l'effort je
remarque à air france certains
personnels l'ont fait l'an déjà fait
beaucoup et que les pilotes aujourd'hui
sont dans une position mais stratégique
d'ailleurs pour la compagnie et qu'ils
ont des efforts à faire mais au moment
où il ya les discussions moi je ne veux
surtout pas rajouter de l'huile sur le
feu il faut trouver un accord et la
corse est celui qui doit permettre à des
pilotes français à des personnels
navigants français à des personnels au
sol français de faire de la compagnie
française une majeure au niveau mondial
ce qu'elle est en passe de ne plus être
aujourd'hui si elle ne prend pas les
décisions qu est ce que vous regrettez
dans votre rapport quand vous dites il
faut une intervention rapide de l'état
est indispensable que je ne regrette
rien mais aucune des propositions et si
l'on prenait toutes les propositions du
rapport pour les mettre en oeuvre ce qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui et je le
regrette cela n'empêcherait pas cela
n'exonérerait pas les compagnies
aériennes de profondes réformes pour
être d'un quantitative et donc ce que je
dis aux salariés ce que je dis aux
organisations syndicales c'est bien
entendu que ce rapport est important
pour assurer la pérennité pour aider le
transport aérien français mais il
n'exonère en rien des décisions qui sont
à prendre en gros pourquoi air france
doit retrouver des coûts unitaires en
baisse une qualité de desserte meilleur
est un service qui soit encore meilleur
que celui qu'elle a aujourd'hui la
survie qui se joue aujourd'hui la survie
d'air france où c'est la survie d'air
france telle que nous la voulons telle
que nous la connaissons aujourd'hui
oui c'est la survie il y aura toujours
et france demain mais la question se
sera est ce que ça donne et d'une
compagnie de seconde zone ou est ce que
c'est une compagnie qui appartiendra en
fin de compte à un autre pays va passer
au mardi un policier grièvement blessé
un braqueur par un braqueur récidiviste
et d'un gouvernement attaqué
lui-même s'est emparée du dossier il
veut faire évoluer la législation sur
les libérations conditionnelles le drame
a pris une vraie tournure politicienne à
l'assemblée nationale écouter cette
passe d'armes entre christiane taubira
et un député mohd un ami nice et le
crédit de la justice qui est en jeu
aujourd'hui vous ne pouvait
éternellement esquivé votre
responsabilité en vous abritant derrière
l'indépendance des juges concernant le
tireur était effectivement considérés
comme état d'évasion en état d'évasion
depuis fin mai 2015 parce qu'il n'avait
pas réintégré la détention à la suite
d'une permission qui lui avait été
octroyé par un juge d'application des
peines pour exécuter des formalités
administratives à la suite du décès
récent de son père au final on se
retrouve avec la traditionnelle formule
un fait divers une loi non pas un fait
divers une loi un fait divers est un
enseignement essayer de tirer les
renseignements absolument de tout
d'abord essayé d'éviter les polémiques
totalement déplacé politicienne cela
s'est passé sur ma circonscription j'ai
vécu avec bernard cazeneuve
la famille était sur place du môle à la
famille quand je parle de la famille
c'est la famille de ce policier mais en
même temps la famille des policiers qui
a été durement touchée et la
récupération qui en est faite quand on
sait qu'aujourd'hui les permissions sont
faites en application par des juges
indépendants certes mais d'un texte de
2004 qui a été voté par la précédente
majorité est ce que je vais dire moi
aujourd'hui c'est leur responsabilité ce
qui s'est passé non quand on sait que
sur toutes les permissions qui ont été
accordées depuis 2004 il y a moins de la
moitié d'un pour cent de problème mais
quand il y a des problèmes et il faut
bien entendu christiane taubira dit il
faut encadrer les sorties avec des
escales introduit sa fameuse jusqu'en
mai et non ça dépend quand il y a
nécessité à ce qu'il y ait une
permission parce qu'il ya un problème à
régler qui justifie la permission quant
à des tenues et dangereux bien ça veut
dire qu'il ne faut pas lui permettre de
s'évader de profiter de cela pour
s'évader et donc qu'il doit y avoir une
escorte et donc c'est en cela qu'il faut
voir si la loi doit être plus précise
mais là encore ramenant les
responsabilités où elles sont
aujourd'hui sur les permissions c'est un
texte la loue perben de 2004 qui les
organisent et il n'y a aucun procès en
laxisme à faire ni à la garde des sceaux
ni au gouvernement fait très grave comme
ce qui s'est passé particulièrement
grave laxisme c'est quand même votre
comme le sparadrap qui vous colle depuis
tant d'années même depuis que vous êtes
au gouvernement laxisme vous pensez que
ça va avec bernard cazeneuve vous pensez
que l'activisme ça va avec manuel de
droite sur ce qu'il dit ce qu'ils
essayent de faire passer mais ce n'est
en aucun cas et ça ne va pas non plus
avec christiane taubira on essaye
d'accrocher sa et christiane taubira
mais est ce que le laxisme c'est d'avoir
voté cette loi en 2004 alors je leur
envoie la balle mais je ne leur fais
même pas ce procès je pense qu'il y a
des lois dont on peut s'apercevoir dans
des cas qui sont des cas très limités
mais dont on doit tirer des
enseignements qu'elle nécessite de faire
évoluer la pratique notre loi qui était
adoptée cette fois ces derniers toujours
mardi exit le tiers payant généralisé
c'est une mesure qui a été décriée par
les médecins libéraux et par la droite
sénatoriale le texte doit à présent
faire l'objet d'une commission mixte
paritaire 7 sénateurs 7 députés qui
devront essayer en tout cas dégager un
compromis a pas de simples badauds mais
le compromis sera le retour au texte qui
était celui de l'assemblée nationale
donc généralisée sur le terrien et moi
je souhaite que le dialogue continu avec
les médecins parce que les conséquences
ne seront pas ce qu'ils disent il n'y
aura pas de restriction la liberté des
patients il n'y aura pas de
déresponsabilisation des tasses patients
il y aura tout simplement une capacité à
mieux prendre en charge et à prendre en
charge plus tôt et toutes les études le
disent et donc nous sommes dans le camp
des médecins car et nous voulons par
cette mesure parce qu'il saisirait mais
c'est parce qu'ils résident à deux
philosophies vous défendez peut-être les
patios et vous défendez pas les médecins
mais nous défendons les deux pour moi le
couple quand on parle de santé le couple
entre le médecin et le patient est
indissociable et le patient doit pouvoir
choisir son médecin il ne peut pas y
avoir de restriction et dans le même
temps il ne doit y avoir non plus aucune
restriction à l'accès or on sait
aujourd'hui que la barrière de l'argent
est encore une barrière dans notre
société entre l'accès aux soins il ya
quand même beaucoup de contestations des
médecins sur ce thème ce sujet
emblématique c'est pas un problème des
virements mais pour moi c'est toujours
pour moi c'est toujours un problème
c'est toujours il faut toujours
expliquer moi je demanderais aux députés
socialistes touche chez le médecin dans
cette période quand on est en deuxième
lecture et qu'on s'aperçoit que l'on n'a
pas réussi bien nous veillerons à y
aller dans les moments où ils ne sont
pas trop occupés mais moi je demanderais
à ce qu'il y ait des contacts
individuels pris dans toutes les
circonscriptions avec les médecins par
téléphone en allant les voir sur le
terrain pour leur dire que la
conséquence n'est pas celle qu on leur
décrit et que c'est une amélioration est
qu'en faisant cela nous faisons de ce
qui est leur métier un très beau métier
un métier encore plus beau dans la
capacité à prendre les problèmes le plus
tôt possible
alors vous ne le roux la fin de vie et
est en débat cette semaine dans
l'hémicycle une proposition de loi qui
propose la sédation profonde et continue
pour les malades en phase terminale
ainsi que des directives anticipées
contraignantes le sujet divise dans
l'es2 quand vous allez le voir avec ce
sujet deux rings à la mer
à gauche tugdual derville membres de
l'alliance vita anti-euthanasie à droite
jean-luc romero défenseurs du droit à
mourir dans la dignité deux points de
vue contradictoires mais une même
opposition au projet de loi sur la fin
de vie premier point prévues par cette
loi les directives anticipées des
consignes laissées par un patient et qui
pourront s'imposer au médecin alors sont
elles une avancée il ya des mots il ya
des exposés des motifs qui nous disent
qu'elles sont opposables c'est à dire
que la vue votre avis si vous l'avez
écrit est obligatoire pour le médecin
dans la réalité c'est totalement faux
elles sont pas opposables si vous avez
mieux s'il ya une urgence vitale donc le
médecin n'a pas le temps de manière
anticipée votre carte vitale et elles
sont pas opposables si le médecin estime
qu'elles sont manifestement
inappropriées ça peut être très
intéressant effectivement qu'il y ait
des directives anticipées dans la loi
mais à condition que ça n'exonère pas
les personnes d'un dialogue avec le
médecin le riz ça serait que le médecin
soit forcé de prendre au mot des
prescriptions du patient mais c'est lui
qui a la compétence deuxième point la
sédation profonde et continue autrement
dit la possibilité d'endormir le patient
est d'arrêter l'alimentation et
l'hydratation tous ceux évidemment qui
dit qu'ils défendent cette sédation
terminale et l'arrêt de l'alimentation
et l'hydratation nous disent qu'il ya
aucune souffrance ils n'ont aucune étude
le risque au fond c'est que face à des
patients qui pose des difficultés qui
sont en grande difficulté il y en a
effectivement on s'arrange avec une
sédation
assorti d'un arrêt d'hydratation et
d'alimentation aux divisions en quelques
jours on provoque la mort globalement le
bilan est négatif pour les deux hommes
alors on parle de la fin de vie
l'actualité c'est aussi cette décision
du tribunal administratif de
châlons-en-champagne qui a rejeté la
demande d'arrêt des traitements qui a
donc refusé d'obliger les médecins à
arrêter le traitement pour vincent
lambert il s'agit du cas vincent lambert
c'est une histoire sans fin pour vous
une histoire tragique que cette
opposition à l'intérieur d'une même
famille sur la façon dont les choses
doivent se terminer et donc je respecte
les décisions de justice je n'ai pas vu
les fondements de la décision du
tribunal que nous avons appris il y à
quelques heures et dans le même temps je
pense que nous devons toujours à
l'assemblée nationale essayer de faire
progresser ce droit des malades cette
capacité à pouvoir
apporter de la dignité écrit moment
particulier l'équilibré n'est pas simple
et c'est pour ça que nous avons choisi
avec un parlementaire de droite reconnu
pour les travaux qu'il a fait même si
nous pensons qu'il faut aller plus loin
jean leonetti un parlementaire de gauche
très très au fait alain claeys sur ces
questions auxquelles le président de la
république avait demandé un rapport et
nous les avons fait travailler ensemble
et le texte que nous avons votée à
l'assemblée nationale peut ne pas
satisfaire il avait des espaces et là
mais il a été voté très largement très
largement mardi en fin d'après midi
parce qu'il représente une avancée et
que sur ce sujet les avancées doivent se
faire pas à pas et essayer de réunir et
moi je suis très fier que sur ce texte
nous n'aurions pas essayer d'opposer
mais essayez de réunion est ce que vous
pensez qu'avec la loi qui a été votée il
n'y aura plus de qazvin selon mehr je ne
peux pas le garantir je ne peux pas le
garantir et donc il faudra très serré où
la loi de garantie n'est d'ailleurs jean
leonetti et alain claeys disent
eux-mêmes que cette loi appellera très
certainement demain de nouveaux débats
et donc une vail loi compte tenu de la
façon niveau législateur c'est les
limites des législateurs sur ces
questions qui touchent aux progrès
d'ailleurs de la médecine qui touchent à
des débats de société qui touche à des
débats philosophiques qui touche et donc
le législateur doit faire attention sur
ces questions a créé du progrès et en
même temps a toujours essayé d'union
donc cette loi et il y aura certainement
d'autres lois c'est ce que vous dites je
pense en tout cas les législateurs même
les principaux disent qu'il faut voter
cette loi donc la mettre en application
mais qu'un autre débat viendra un
premier pas vraiment d'autres débats
viendront vous avez peut-être vu on est
toujours mardi vous avez peut-être vu au
sénat des nouvelles questions
d'actualité mais peut-être fait
attention tout à fait en tant que
présidente groupe très intéressant c'est
une nouvelle formule fait du nouveau
règlement du sénat il y avait sur 348
sénateurs presque 305 présent dans ses
murs dans l'hémicycle et pendant ce
temps là à l'assemblée nationale et
claude bartolone lui il a dit si les
questions d'actualité de toujours ce
spectacle que l'on voit
traditionnellement et bien je serai prêt
à ne plus les télévisée qu'est ce que
vous avez pensé je préside le groupe du
parti socialiste je pense que
l'introduction de la télé on le voit
bien sur les débats tels que les débats
fin de vie elle ne change en rien la
nature des débats et pourtant ils sont
télévisés vous-même d'ailleurs fait ce
travail aujourd'hui de rendre public
mais sur internet on peut voir les
débats en continu donc aujourd'hui il y
à cette publicité par l'image de nos
débats les séances de questions
d'actualité
j'ai quelquefois l'impression d'être
dans un stade avec des comportements de
son et comportements inadmissibles avec
des choses qu'on ne fait et je le dis à
nos téléspectateurs dans aucune autre
réunion dans aucune autre séance de
l'assemblée nationale ou d'un seul coup
on entend des insultes on entend des
cris est estimé par ailleurs le badge
mercredi bien sûr lâché s'il fallait
pour cela pour que personne ne se lâche
et que chacun respecte l'autre je le dis
aussi en y prenant ma part pour le le
camp qui est le mien je le dis souvent
aux députés le mardi matin quand je
prépare les questions d'actualité je
demande à ce qu'il y ait de la décence
je demande à ce qu'il y ait de la
retenue et on vous dit d'aller plus loin
les questions rien dire mais alors la
proposition de claude bartolone de dire
bière si c'est la télé qui entraîne cela
alors il faudrait le plus télévisé je le
regretterai pour les téléspectateurs
mais si pendant un certain temps cela
peut faire comprendre aux députés que
tout n'est pas permis dans cette séance
là parce que claude bartolone reçoit le
courrier moi je ne le vois pas tout mais
il nous transmet quelquefois les
courriels téléspectateurs pour les
députés je pense que c'est celle il ya
des comportements qui ne sont pas
admissibles aux débats ça fait partie de
la vie ça ne fait pas partie de la vie
parlementaire l'un le lol le débat le
débat mais l'insu je ne fais pas partie
de la vie parlementaire et je
préférerais que dans la vie
parlementaire on ne soit pas tout le
temps en train de se couper ou tout le
temps en train de se muer et d'ailleurs
les débats quelques des clans dépasse
les questions d'actualité les débats
prennent un cours nouveau plus apaisé ce
n'est pas moins fort sur le fond il ya
des débats des mis en cause de la
contradiction mais leur état la
rencontre à dix alors on reste à
l'assemblée après de longues tractations
vonau l'heure où les écologistes ont
trouvé une solution pour tenter de
sauver leur groupe cécile duflot prend
la co présidence du groupe en
remplacement de françois de rugy est ce
que pour vous c'est un bon choix et ce
qu'elle fera une bonne cause président
je ne fais pas nous avions accepté qu'il
y ait une coprésidence qu'il oeuvrait
pour un seul groupe à l'assemblée
nationale sur la base de la parité c'est
ce qui nous avait été demandé ce que
vous pensez à ce choix mais je ne pense
rien de ses choix c'est au groupe de
s'organiser j'ai bien vu qu'il ya là un
groupe qui est divisé en deux parties et
qui a donné une coprésidence à chacun
des représentants des deux parties moi
je souhaite que sur le maximum de textes
nous soyons en situation nous le groupe
majoritaire de réunir les deux parties
moi c'est ce qui m'importe est alors
avec cécile duflot se passe passe et
comment ils te disent qu'ils discuteront
elle est en situation unique au
président c'est donc pour moi elle est
l'interlocutrice normal une des deux
interlocutrices du groupe vers ton pas
ce que je ferai tout pour que nous
prenez pas encore 2017 mais s'il veut
visiblement elle veut être candidate à
l'élection présidentielle ça va être
compliqué mon ensemble unis mais vous
savez pour être candidat
quand on n'est pas candidat sont espérer
gagner pour en espérer faire quelque
chose de fort et non pour que nous
fassions quelque chose de fort nous
avons besoin de discuter ensemble
on passe à un autre sujet mercredi
l'état de catastrophe naturelle est
déclarée dans les communes sinistrées
par les inondations
la question était à l'ordre du jour du
conseil des ministres et le gouvernement
a promis une indemnisation rapide des
victimes écouter bernard cazeneuve
l'arrêté catastrophe naturelle sera
publié dès demain j'ai réuni hier les
compagnies d'assurances de manière à ce
que dès la publication de cet arrêté de
catastrophe naturelle les victimes qui
ont déclaré leur cynisme puisse être
immédiatement situation percevoir des
avances de la part des compagnies
d'assurance alors on entend beaucoup de
critiques ici et là on entendu beaucoup
de critiques sur ce qu'on aurait pu
faire l'état aussi sur les verts qui ont
attaqué le gouvernement en disant que
certains budgets ont été taillés
notamment le budget de météo france est
ce que pour vous c'est sérieux ses
arguments je pars toujours trouver les
responsables je pense qu'il faut
regarder les procédures météo france
mais ce n'est pas une question de budget
l' alerte a été donnée et je crois que
s'il y avait pu avoir une mauvaise
interprétation ou une interprétation qui
n'a pas été aussi fine c'est parce que
tout simplement les événements
climatiques ne sont pas totalement
maîtrisable qu'ils se sont fixés à un
endroit avec une violence qui avaient
des difficultés à être prévue donc moi
je pense qu'il faut réfléchir à la façon
dont ont été organisées à ces zones
c'est peut-être beaucoup plus
intéressant mais en même temps cela ne
date pas là encore aujourd'hui c'est des
décisions qui ont été prises il ya 15 20
ans ça pose aussi la question
quelquefois des moeurs qu'il peut y
avoir et de la façon dont il y a eu des
rapports entre ceux qui donnaient des
autorisations pour construire est le
seul qui construisait dans ces régions
et aussi des responsabilités
individuelles vous dites il faut voir
tout cela voilà faut voir toutes les
fois tous les essayer sur un thé du
doigt un acteur unique ce véritablement
toujours 20 sur ce type de données
l'euro est ce qu'il faudrait pour cela
une mission parlementaire soit des
députés des sénateurs ou pourquoi pas
des 2 mai sur l'événement lui même nom
sur la capacité aujourd'hui d'une région
dont on voit bien que les cours naturel
dole et les pentes qui permettent
l'évacuation ont été perturbés depuis
plusieurs décennies par les
constructions et donc pour éviter les
problèmes pourquoi pas et ont continué à
construire sur des zones qu'on dit ils
ont dame donc c'est ça que je l'étais
pas si on continue à le faire en tout
cas je sais qu'on l'a fait pendant de
très nombreuses années qu'il y a des
responsabilités qu'on ne peut pas
rejeter sur météo france aujourd'hui ou
sur l'état le gouvernement des
responsabilités qui sont quand même
établi depuis plusieurs décennies une
porte ouverte en tout cas pour une
possible mission par le moteur il y
avait nécessité un type de mission
parlementaire c'est pas une mission
parlementaire de mise en cause si un
jour elle devait glisse nommé d'études
des pour essayer de comprendre d'étudier
les cas et de trouver les préconisations
alors le droit des étrangers et débattu
au sénat toute la semaine la droite à
muscler la version issue de l'assemblée
nationale elle souhaite s'attaquer à
l'immigration illégale ont reçu sont
notamment les conditions d'accès au
regroupement familial ce que les
explications avec géraldine bah voyons
et fabrice qu'une et la parole est à
monsieur karoutchi qui on demande le
retrait de l'amendement
même en rêve non une droite sénatoriale
inflexible face à une gauche qui défend
l'esprit initial du texte le ton est
donné pour les discussions du projet de
loi qui vise à mieux encadrer l'accueil
des immigrés sommes réunis cette nuit
pour examiner le projet de loi relatif
au droit des étrangers ou plutôt
désormais le projet de loi relatifs à la
maîtrise de l'immigration
ce changement d'intitulé voulue par la
droite en commission en dit long sur
l'état d'esprit avec laquelle lequel
pardon à lasbordes aux travaux le
ministre de l'intérieur est inquiet sur
fond de crise migratoire la droite veut
durcir le texte tandis que la gauche
plaide pour un meilleur accueil moi je
forme le voeu que sur la question
migratoire le débat s'apaisent qu'on ne
cherche pas instrumentaliser cette
question qui est une question
douloureuse pour des milliers d'hommes
et de femmes à des fans politique
intérieure que l'on ne préempte pas ce
sujet pour faire peur la commission veut
restreindre les droits des étrangers les
conditions de résidence pour le
regroupement familial rallonger les
dispositifs de contrôles renforcés enfin
en ce qui concerne le titre de séjour
valable le plusieurs années le sénat
réclame des conditions plus sévères pour
son attribution
nous l'avons donné un peu d'efficacité
pour remplir des objectifs que je crois
partagée qui est celui d'une immigration
régulière parfaitement contenu qui est
celui d'une migration régulière
parfaitement combattu avec un
éloignement plus efficace que le texte
ne prévoyait en arrivant dans cette
assemblée merci au sénat la droite
demande également l'insertion dans la
loi d'un débat annuel sur la politique
d'immigration
le fait qu'on ait des baptisés que la
droite ait voulu débaptiser le texte
pour la maîtrise de l'immigration ça a
donné un petit peu le tour des débats
est-ce que c'est dans le contexte actuel
de crise me guette migratoire interdit
de se poser des questions il faut
toujours se poser les questions c'est
pour ça qu'il y ait un texte et en même
temps il faut se poser les bonnes
questions il faut essayer d'éviter les
effets
je vais prendre un exemple il n'y avait
jamais eu aussi peu de reconduite à la
frontière que sous le quinquennat de
nicolas sarkozy depuis 2012 il y à
chaque année plus de reconduite à la
frontière qu'il n'y en avait tout
simplement parce que nous voulons le
respect de la loi quant à l'étranger les
plans situation de se maintenir en
france nous voulons qu'il soit expulsé
et qu'ils repartent dans le pays son
pays d'origine mais par contre nous
voulons avoir des procédures qui soit
claire qui soit simplifié qui puisse
être beaucoup plus rapide vers ceux qui
ont vocation à rester dans notre pays et
donc c'est un débat qui ne peut pas être
un débat de mise en cause comme je lai
entendu au sénat ou de dire que
l'immigration de toute façon ne serait
jamais maîtrisé donc il faudrait
endurcir toujours les procédures on voit
bien que deux salles de sa part d'une
volonté nous nous voulons de la clarté
dans les procédures et en même temps de
la maîtrise et de l'efficacité quand il
n'y a pas eu de droits accordés c'est
pas facile à respecter comme à trouver
comme équilibre mais l équilibre il est
le respect des textes et le respect des
textes vous savez ça ne peut pas être la
droite c'était de la parole et du
laxisme c'était u2 la mise en cause
auparavant la question de l'immigration
en fin de compte il n'est pas sérieux
pour la droite c'est un thème un thème
de débat et plus ça se dégrade et
peut-être le politicien de certains
politiciens bien entendu et plus ça se
dégrade et plus à lui faire c'est son
fond de commerce e cela et c'est bien
pour ça qu'elle faisait par exemple
beaucoup moins de reconduite à la
frontière que nous parce que ça lui
permettait toujours de dire que ça ne
marchait pas que ceux qui étaient en
situation irrégulière ça ne devait pas
pouvoir se passer et surtout nous
voulons le respect des textes et le
respect des hommes et des femmes alors
ces thèmes là sont en tout cas au coeur
de l'agenda européen
on parle d'europe avec mercredi cette
image historique françois hollande un
gala merkel côte à côte au parlement
européen pour relancer une europe en
berne le couple franco-allemand et
notamment le président français a
toutefois été pris à partie à cette
occasion par marine le pen dans
l'hémicycle de strasbourg écouter cet
échange
merci madame merkel de nous faire le
plaisir de venir aujourd'hui avec votre
vice chancelier administrateur de la
province france
monsieur le vice chancelier
j'aurais aimé pouvoir vous appeler
monsieur le président de la république
par respect pour votre fonction mais pas
plus que votre prédécesseur vous
n'exercez cette présidence à président
de la république ne pourrais pas dire le
souverainisme c'est le déclinisme comme
vous venez de le faire parce que le
président de la république est garant de
la constitution française et que le
titre 1 de la constitution française et
de la souveraineté et que j'appelle ici
ce n'est pas l'abandon de la
souveraineté c'est la souveraineté et la
souveraineté n'a rien à voir avec le
souverainiste la souveraineté européenne
ce et capable de décider pour nous mêmes
et d'éviter que ce soit le retour au
nationalisme au populisme aux
extrémistes qui nous impose aujourd'hui
d'aller dans un chemin que nous n'avons
pas voulu aller se changer et violent
d'années ce que cela augure du débat qui
aura lieu en 2017 pour home et madame le
pen a décidé d'installer un climat
violent et quand on voit que la
stratégie c'est d'aller dans une
instance européenne pour essayer de
salir la france pour essayer de prendre
à partie le président de la république
on voit bien toute la violence la
vulgarité jeu les dix ans elle est
incapable à ce moment-là quitte les
français ne peuvent pas accepter cela
donc elle veut placer la campagne sur un
terrain violent mais en même temps elle
le place aussi sur un terrain où elle
salit notre pays et dans ses propos tout
est toujours fait pour salir notre pays
je demande à ce qu'on réfléchisse à sa
n'avons pas intérêt demain ni en europe
ni dans le monde à avoir un pays qu'ils
soient moins respectée alors qu'il a
retrouvé toute sa place aujourd'hui on a
quand même l'impression que françois
hollande il a choisi son adversaire pour
2010 est dans le ton qu'il a employé la
façon parler parce qu'il a créé ce
face-à-face également non mais notre
adversaire c'est leur pays la france sur
elle même c'est le populisme c'est la
montée l'exacerbation des tensions je
vous parle de l'adversaire politique en
vue d'une campagne mais moi je mets moi
je vous dis aujourd'hui je ne sais pas
si ces idées sont partagées uniquement
par madame le pen c'est pour cela que je
dis que l'adversaire n'est pas
aujourd'hui ce qui serait prêt désigner
l'adversaire aujourd'hui il est une
analyse de ce qu'est la france et de ce
qu'elle doit être demain qui est erronée
la france n'a pas exacerber les tensions
dans la société
pour respecter ce qui serait son
identité son identité aujourd'hui est
basé sur la capacité à vivre ensemble
sur un modèle social et quand j'ai vu
l'interview de monsieur sarkozy il ya
quelques jours aux échos et la façon
qu'ils rejetaient la totalité de ce
modèle social je me dis qu'il y a là des
propos c'est pareil mais je ne dis pas
que c'est pareil je vous disais que
c'est une consécration de la france
aujourd'hui contre laquelle nous nous
battrons alors qu'ils ont la même
conception de la france dit non ils ont
des conceptions différentes de la france
dont il est dit que totalement différent
comment c'est totalement différent et je
ne dis pas que c'est totalement
différent je dis qu'il y a aujourd'hui
des lignes de conjonction entre la
droite et l'extrême droite qui sont très
fortes sur un certain nombre de sujets
et d'analystes sur notre pays que moi je
rejette ces analyses les considère comme
totalement fausse a eu des polémiques
depuis une dizaine de jours celle de
nadine morano on en vient aux
explications très médiatisée
une formulation d' excuses aux français
mais pas à son parti après ses propos
sur la race blanche pour nadine morano
on l'a sanctionné nicolas sarkozy a
commis une faute politique écoutez
nadine morano elle était invitée du
journal de 20 heures de tf1
quand j'entends nicolas sarkozy dire la
france n'est pas une rage n'ai jamais
dit ça donc ça me choque lui qui avait
pourtant une liberté d'expression je
crois qu'il fait une faute politique
majeure que de dire de dire cela et de
ne pas laisser vivre le débat ou de dire
mais qu'est ce qu'elle a voulu dire que
sera la france demain avec c'est vrai
cette vague migratoire que nous allons
vivre comment est-ce qu'on s'organise ce
sont des vrais problèmes qu'il faut dont
il faut parler en français
alors avant vous répondiez je vous
présente gym jarrassé notre partenaire
du scan lefigaro.fr qui nous a rejoints
sur sa bouche pour moi ce sera vous dans
quelques sites dont quelques minutes
tout d'abord sur nadine morano nicolas
sarkozy est il bien géré le dossier ça
ne m'appartient pas de dire s'il a bien
géré ou pas c'est un dossier partisans
moi je regarde les propos et les propos
étaient totalement inadmissible répétées
et inadmissibles et c'est le propos d'un
d'un siècle passé aujourd'hui rien ne
peut justifier cela est encore plus en
france ou bien entendu que les races
n'existent pas plus ici qu'ailleurs mais
où nous avons la capacité et ce sur quoi
nous devrions être arquebouté c'est la
laïcité c'est la capacité à vivre
ensemble et à faire partager cette idée
c'est pas à essayer de mettre en cause
et a parlé de vagues l'un l'une est dans
la vague l'autre et dans la chasse d'eau
nicolas sarkozy enfin toutes ces
affaires aujourd'hui cette façon donc un
gars l'ifi l'immigration c'est façon
dont on qualifie les immigrés et nicolas
sarkozy de dire il n'y a pas de race il
n'y a pas de couleur dans la république
française mais il commet en solo mais il
a raison de dire cela et n'importe quel
républicain devrait aujourd'hui dire
cela donc donc nadine morano ce n'est
pas une républicaine dans ses propos la
non quand on distingue aujourd'hui les
races à l'intérieur de notre pays ça
n'appartient pas à la république ça
n'appartient pas non plus à la génétique
énième énième signe de l'organisation
des esprits pour vous mais en tout cas
on y aime signe d'une course-poursuite
sur un certain nombre l'idée que ce
livre aujourd'hui une partie de la
droite pensante qu'il en va de son salut
aujourd'hui que d'aller chercher sur ce
terrain elle a réussi son coup
médiatiquement parlant bien rien que la
question
n'appelle je pense aucune réponse
au nom revient à la loupe du skate avec
notre partenaire john gerassi
bruno le roux bonjour une question pour
commencer
quelles fonctions occupe rage le drian
en 2016 mise de la défense au président
de la région bretagne c'est un débat qui
ressurgit cette semaine alors si on s'en
tient à la règle du non cumul entre un
poste de ministre et un mandat dans un
exécutif local qui a été mise en vigueur
en 2012 il va devoir faire un choix à
moins qu'ils puissent profiter d'une
dérogation et qu'ils puissent mener de
front les deux les deux missions
marylise lebranchu qui est l'autre
ministre bretonne 1 du gouvernement y
est favorable qu'est ce que vous en
pensez mais moi je pense qu'il ne peut
pas y avoir deux ministres qui soit en
charge d'une collectivité que c'est que
le premier ministre et le président de
la république est stricte de la règle
oui ils ne l'accepteront bien entendu
pas et donc le souhait que je forme pour
2016 c'est que jean yves le drian reste
ministre de la défense et que nous ayons
en décembre 2015 conserver la région
pottas govou ne souhaitait pas qui mène
la campagne en tête de liste en région
bretagne je pense que jean yves le drian
et à s'identifier pour être présents
dans cette campagne sans être en
position de devenir président de la
région mais c'est à lui de le dire il
l'annoncera je pense dans quelques jours
mais ce que je souhaite bien entendu
c'est qu'ils puissent continuer à
apporter le savez les faits
de sa diplomatie de sa capacité à
comprendre de sa capacité à agir vous
êtes en mesure d'être proche des gens il
vous a fait mal cette décision non mes
parents je pense que sur un sujet comme
ça il en discutera jusqu'au dernier
moment avec le président de la
république est ce que vous connaissez un
bruno le roux le film un jour sans fin
avec bill murray ait un film des années
90 c'est l'histoire d'un homme qui vit
chaque jour la même journée encore et
encore ce personnage ça pourrait
peut-être être un peu vous dans le rôle
du patron des députés ps à l'assemblée
il ya un an vous écriviez aux députés
pour les convaincre de voter le budget
c'était finalement abstenu je parle des
députés frondeurs un an plus tard on a
l'impression que la situation est un peu
la même laurent baumel encore cette
semaine dit si rien ne bouge il sera
difficile de boue de voter le budget
vous n'êtes pas un peu lassé et vous
vous rendez compte le budget c'est
revient chaque année comme noël et le
nouvel an ouais mec à quels problèmes
mais toujours là et chaque année être
obligé je parle pas du budget je parle
de la foulée moi je la fronde vous savez
moi j'ai dit à chacun de prendre ses
responsabilités et j'ai dit aux
frondeurs depuis maintenant plusieurs
mois que j'étais prêt à toute discussion
avec eux mais qu'il n'empêcherait jamais
aucun texte de passe et qu'il ne
pourrait pas se mettre en travers de la
majorité et la majorité elle s'exprime
au sein du groupe de 181 8 députés
aujourd'hui quand on parle des frondeurs
on parle de 20 à 30 de mes collègues et
il vous est ce un an mais quand même 250
de l'autre côté on en a entendu un
certain nombre tout à l'heure et donc le
budget sera voté ce que je leur dis
simplement c'est que cette année il ya
peut-être une différence par rapport
l'année dernière c'est que nous sommes
aussi en campagne régionale et qu'il y a
une forme d' aberration à être à lhassa
la salle des quatre colonnes de
l'assemblée nationale à aller voir le
figaro alors dire que ils ont raison la
politique comme elle le gouvernement
n'est pas une politique de gauche et le
soir à aller distribuer les tracts avec
nous parce qu'on est sur la même liste
aux élections régionales donc ça c'est
là une double faute en période de
campagne bien entendu de 2,2 mais
melanie brown repères notre gouvernement
d'abord ce budget un budget que j'assume
totalement avec fierté comme l'action
que nous avons menée depuis trois ans
mais quand on est sur les mêmes listes
régionales on a plutôt intérêt à ne pas
aller semer le doute par les
déclarations successives au fil d'une
journée dans l'esprit de nos électeurs
vous parler de ce cousin est ce qu'un
jour vous pourriez menacé par exemple
les frondeurs de tout simplement joue je
dis vous l'exécutif de ne pas leur
accorder de circonscription en 2017 si
jamais il continua à s'opposer à la
politique du beurre c'est une question
qui sera réglée par le parti mais c'est
une question qui peut se poser bien
entendu il ya peut-être un certain
nombre d'endroits où elle peut s'opposer
déjà sur le terrain par la réaction des
militants est bien entendu que ces
choses peuvent se poser moi je souhaite
toujours réunir mais à l'évidence si un
certain nombre de députés ne votez pas
le budget à un an et demi les élections
cette question pourrait se poser huit
minutes
ce qui agace les fondeurs c'est aussi
l'habitude qu'a prise le gouvernement de
modifier ses projets de loi alors que
son examen a débuté au parlement ce fut
notamment le cas de la loi
renseignements claude bartolone cette
semaine dans sa conférence de presse de
rentrée a souhaité que l'exécutif
s'interdisent d'amendé ses propres
textes est ce que vous êtes favorable ça
c'est pas c'est pas une réaction des
frondeurs c'est une réaction du groupe
les députés oui les démentant dans leur
ensemble souhaitent que que je porte au
nom du groupe la qualité de la loi
aujourd'hui tient à la capacité à la
préparer en amont et à ne pas voir
arriver à la dernière minute des
articles additionnels qui n'ont pas pu
passer au conseil d'état qui n'ont pas
pu passer ensuite le filtre d examen en
commission concrètement comment on fait
pour mettre ça en place pour que l'on
devrait le monde on ne concernerait plus
en amont ensemble on nomme des
rapporteur à l'assemblée nationale plus
tôt et les ministres de sept records ils
ont interdit au mas modifier leurs
textes au dernier moment ça c'est clair
si les messins merci et bon va
poursuivre on va quitter la france bruno
le roux pour traverser la manche
c'est une menace qui pèse sur l'europe
et sur la tête de david cameron le break
sitcom bri exit la royaume uni hors
d'europe les britanniques seront
consultés par référendum pour savoir
s'ils veulent que leur pays reste ou non
dans l'europe alexandre darmon a pris le
pouls de la population dans les rues de
londres écouter
aujourd'hui un micro-trottoir spéciale
os prêchant micro trop tard demain à
londres terre 43 % des britanniques ont
dit dans un sondage vouloir sortir de
l'europe alors quand vraiment il fallait
que je repose la question allait annuler
anglaise
blumstein
m
thébaux mais comme quoi tout arrive en
angleterre même ça peut arriver
mais alice anglais pour le coup ne sont
pas si seulement envie de rester dans
l'espace
pas laisser partir
non
jean claude juncker
je leur parle de vous les personnes qui
connaissent
que je continue et je continue je
n'arrête pas
voilà pour ce micro trottoir dans les
rues de nombre est ce que le break site
vous concerne c' est ce que ça concerne
la france oui oui à l'évidence
le fait de sortir de l'europe même si
l'employé peut intégrer en fin de compte
et aux intéressés aussi on vous émeut
peut intéresser justement c'est le
résultat et qui le dira moi je crois
qu'il ya un danger à faire ce type de
questions mais maintenant la démocratie
si elle doit s'exprimer s'exprimera moi
je vous souhaite bien entendu que le
royaume uni puisse rester dans l'europe
merci beaucoup pour nous l'aurons
d'avoir participé à part le mojito merci
merci cathy on se retrouvait semaine
prochaine la semaine prochaine merci à
tous de votre fidélité bonne suite au
programme sa chaîne parlementaire bye
bye